J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So We've
been talking about
oxidation and reduction.
And today we're going to talk
about a very special kind of
oxidation by iodic acid.
Periodate, that is to say.
Periodate cleavage of diols.
Carbonyl with an alcohol, then.
Let's try that.
Carbonyl with two alcohol
molecules.
STUDENT: The chromium, which is
double-bonded with the
oxygens, and then--
PROFESSOR: Don't think about the
chromium.
Just for the terms of the
analog, suppose that was a
carbonyl group.
Instead of I=O, suppose it was
C=O
What reaction do you get?
STUDENT: Is it a esterification?
PROFESSOR: Not esterification.
You could imagine esterification
of an
acid with an ester[correction:
alcohol].
But I said not...Suppose it's
not a--
suppose it were a carbonyl
group, C=O. No OH
on the group up at top.
What reaction do you get between
a ketone--
yeah, Matt?
STUDENT: Form a ketal.
PROFESSOR: A ketale, right?
So you get a reaction that's
just like that.
A ketale forms. And now we have
a thing that's a little
bit like ozone, because this
sort of ketale can unzip.
That's what reminds you a little
bit of ozone,
that kind of thing.
So it can come apart that way.
And notice what's happened is
that the diol has become two
carbonyls, and of course that's
an oxidation.
The iodine started in oxidation
state +7, right,
seven bonds to oxygen, and it
ended in +5.
So the iodine is reduced, and at
the same time, the carbon
is oxidized.
It's +1 here and it's +2 over
here.
And two of them get oxidized.
Two carbons get oxidized.
Now, this might remind you of
this reaction, where you get
two carbonyls.
And what reaction is that?
What reagent will do that?
STUDENT: Is that ozone?
PROFESSOR: That's ozone, right?
What reagent does it?
Ozone.
So it's nice to think about,
when you have a certain
functional group you want to
get, what reaction
will lead to it.
So there's one that will lead to
that.
We could also think, what
reaction would come back from
two ketones to give a diol with
a
carbon-carbon bond in between?
That's a more exotic reaction.
Does anybody remember that one?
That's the pinacol reduction
that we talked about, where
metals give electrons to the
ketones, the radicals couple,
and then you have
two O's that get
hydrogens on them.
So that's the pinocol reduction
that we mentioned.
And then you might wonder if
there's a reaction that does
that, right?
And we'll see an indirect
version of that
later in this lecture.
That involves the Wittig
reaction, which is familiar to
you from lab.
So periodic acid, cleavage of
carbohydrates, is
a diagnostic tool.
This is a useful reaction.
It's actually used to prepare
compounds.
But it also was historically
important in finding out the
ring size of sugars that we
talked about
earlier as a problem.
Remember, nowadays you do that
kind of thing by NMR, but in
the early days, you had to do
chemical transformations to
known compounds in order to
figure out what something was.
So if you have a diol, as we
just showed, you could react
it with periodic acid and get
two aldehydes.
In particular for this one,
formaldehyde.
So remember what sugars are, are
a bunch of
carbons in a row.
They're carbohydrates.
So it's carbon-hydrate, OHH, and
then the carbons link
together, and one end is CH2OH,
typically, and the
other end is an aldehyde.
Or the carbonyl could be other
positions down the chain.
But how do you figure out what
they are?
Suppose you had three in a row
and did periodic acid.
OK, so you react with one of
them, and get the formaldehyde
out from the end.
But from the bottom part there,
you get another
aldehyde and OH.
And that reacts again with
periodic acid.
Now, why?
Because remember, the aldehydes
form hydrates, so
they're equivalent in
water to alcohols.
So now we have a diol again, and
periodic acid oxidizes and
cleaves such diols.
So from this reaction, then, you
get two
formaldehyde molecules.
And the one in the middle, which
had only one hydrogen on
the carbon, gives formic acid,
So formaldehyde arises from
the primary alcohols at the end
of the chain, and formic
acid from the ones in the middle
of the chain, that have
just an H on them.
And incidentally, I've taken
these slides from lectures
given in the course last year by
Professor Ziegler, because
he had nicely animated them
already.
So here's that reaction we just
talked about.
Now, suppose we had an aldehyde
at the end of the
chain and we did this.
Now the one...not only the one
in the middle of the chain has
only one H on it, but the one at
the top has only one H.
So from that one, you'd get a
formaldehyde and two formic
acids, right?
Or if the carbonyl were in the
middle of the chain,
you're going to get formaldehyde
and the acid in
the middle.
But that acid in the middle
itself can hydrate and be
oxidized and give CO2.
So from this one, we get two
aldehydes, two formaldehydes,
and a CO2 molecule.
So now we could go down and see
what groups where that R
includes an adjacent H, right,
and what products
you'd get from them.
Formaldehyde, formic acid, and
carbon dioxide.
So that just summarizes what we
just looked at.
Now suppose you had glucose.
Now, the top would give formic
acid, the next one would be
formic acid, formic acid, formic
acid, formic acid.
The bottom would be
formaldehyde, because there
were two Hs on it.
If you had mannitol, a reduced
form related to glucose, then
the top would be formaldehyde,
two Hs, then acid, acid, acid,
acid, and at the bottom would be
formaldehyde.
So you see, the ratio of these
various well-known products
you get out tell you something
about what the structure of
the sugar was.
Or if you had fructose, which
has a ketone in it, you get
formaldehyde from the top, CO2
now from the one that has no
hydrogens at all.
Acid, acid, acid, formaldehyde.
And you can also apply it to the
question of the ketals
that are formed when you form a
ring.
So remember, we spoke before
about this ketal being a
protecting group.
Both for the aldehyde that was
formerly here--
and that's its oxygen--
and for the alcohol that was
here.
OK?
Now, we talked about the problem
with
determining the ring size.
Think what would happen with
this with HIO4.
So it would cleave those two
bonds where there
are adjacent OHs.
Right?
Vicinal.
Those are the only places where
there are adjacent OHs.
So it would give formic acid--
there was one H on
that central carbon--
and aldehydes on the end.
And now if you treated that with
acid and heat, then you'd
open up the ketal, right?
Ketals could be opened by acid.
Incidentally, people don't
typically notice the necessity
for heat in this, but it must
require heat.
Because if you can get that
product, which hasn't opened
the ketal in the first reaction,
which is done at
room temperature for a day,
periodic
acid is a strong acid.
So here's water--
and it's done in water.
So it's water with an acid
catalyst.
You'd think it would take the
ketal apart.
But in fact taking the ketal
apart requires some heat.
So that's done in the second
step.
And then you get the aldehyde
taken apart.
So the pieces you get are--
from the piece up here, you get
OH, OH, and aldehyde.
So you get D-glyceraldehyde.
From the piece over here you get
aldehyde
and aldehyde again.
And finally, of course, there's
methanol that came
along, because it was a ketal
involving that alcohol.
So by telling what the products
are, you can tell
what the ring size was.
Now, here's a problem for you to
think about.
Suppose you could imagine these
ketals being formed with
other-- instead of this OH being
the one that's involved
to make a six-membered ring, it
could have been this OH and
made a five-membered ring.
Or in principle, this one that
made a four, or that one that
made a seven-membered ring.
I'd like you to make a table
that shows what the products
would have been for periodic
oxidation of those others to
see whether, in fact, you could
prove what the ring size
was by what products come out
from this.
This reaction was developed in
1928 and
applied for that purpose.
That analytical purpose.
OK, so that's oxidation.
Now we're going to talk about a
little bit of reduction, and
in particular, about
synthesizing alcohols and the
idea of retrosynthesis a little
bit.
Which is, you look at the
product-- usually it's a
product you want to have, and
you're trying to figure out
what starting materials and
reagents would have given it.
So really, you're working
backwards, rather than
forwards, in a synthesis.
So analyzing such problems is
called retrosynthesis, and
we'll engage in a little bit of
this here, using a problem
that occurs in the Jones
textbook.
OK.
So here's an alcohol we want to
get.
We want to put R on an alcohol
that already has two methyls.
Now, we can start with acetone.
There are the two methyls.
And now we have to put the R on.
Now, what kind of R do we need
in order to attack a carboile?
What will attack a carbonyl to
make a
carbon-carbon bond for R?
What form of R will we use?
For example, could you use an
alkyl halide, RCl?
Would that be something that
would react in order to give
this product?
What is it that will react with
a carbonyl?
What makes a carbonyl
reactive? Ruoyi?
STUDENT: You need a nucleophile.
PROFESSOR: You need a
nucleophile.
So you need a carbon that has a
high HOMO on it.
Can you think of any such
things?
Where do you got a high HOMO on
a carbon?
STUDENT: From a Grignard.
PROFESSOR: From a Grignard
reaction, or an alkyl lithium.
Something where R is attached to
a metal ion,
so it'll be R minus.
OK.
So you have R with a metal, like
a Grignard reagent or an
alkyl lithium, right?
You do this reaction.
Then, of course, those electrons
could be used to
form a bond to the metal, and
you get that intermediate.
And in fact, as we've already
discussed, it's not so obvious
what the order of those
additions are, the R added to
carbon and the metal added to
oxygen.
It could be either first or in
fact probably
both at the same time.
So anyhow, we can make that new
carbon-carbon bond, and
then treat the salt, the O minus
M plus, with H plus, and
get the alcohol.
So there's a simple synthesis.
Now, suppose we wanted to put an
H on instead of an R. What
form of H do we need?
Can we do this with an acid, for
example, H plus?
Is that going to
be a good idea? Megan?
What type of the reagent, what
kind of H,
would attack a carbonyl?
What makes the carbonyl
reactive?
STUDENT: The low LUMO
PROFESSOR: Low LUMO.
So you need an H with a high
HOMO.
How about proton?
STUDENT: Oh, no.
PROFESSOR: No, protons have no
electrons at all.
So what form of H do you need?
STUDENT: H minus.
PROFESSOR: H minus.
Where are you going to get H
minus?
Where did you get R minus?
STUDENT: From R-Metal.
PROFESSOR: R-metal.
So what do we do now?
STUDENT: H-Metal.
PROFESSOR: H-metal.
So this is going to be a hydride
reduction, OK?
So we have H with a metal, doing
exactly the same thing
we showed above, except it's H
minus instead of R
minus doing the trick.
And we get it from something
like H attached to aluminum
with a minus charge on the
aluminum, which means it's
really going to be a high HOMO.
Or H attached to boron with a
minus charge on it.
So those reagents are lithium
aluminum hydride, sodium
borohydride, which can reduce an
alcohol to
put the H on there.
And we also talked about the
biological equivalent of these
hydride donors, which is NADH,
where the unshared pair on the
nitrogen can get into the, act
forming an aromatic system and
losing H minus, which can go
onto the carbonyl group.
So we have R minus or H minus as
ways to
attack carbonyl groups.
Now let's look a little bit at
the synthetic versatility of
Grignard reagents.
So here's a problem.
To suggest high yield syntheses
where the carbons
come only from alcohols with no
more than three carbons,
but you can use any other
reagent.
Now, these are very artificial.
These are not a problem you'd be
faced with in the
laboratory, because many of
these you could buy.
Not all of them, but many of
them you could buy cheaper
than you could make them.
Right?
But in a way of thinking about
how you do syntheses in an
elementary way, this is a good
exercise.
And as I mentioned here, you can
find that problem in the
Jones textbook.
So let's think first about the
first molecule in this list.
Now, what problem do we face in
making this from alcohols with
no more than three carbons?
There are four carbons in it.
So we've got to make a
carbon-carbon bond somehow.
So let's think about what
carbon-carbon
bonds we might make.
We could make the first
carbon-carbon bond, nearest
the OH, or the next one, or the
next one.
There are three that we could
make.
And let's see how we would go
about that.
First let's try to make the one
adjacent to the H. So we
need to have two carbons that
will react with one another,
one a high HOMO the other the
low LUMO, that will
establish that bond.
So we need a nucleophile, a high
HOMO, and an
electrophile, the low LUMO.
So what will the nucleophile be?
Anybody got an idea?
It could be either the piece on
the left or the
piece on the right.
If the electrophile were the
piece on the left, the three
carbon, what kind of molecule
would you do use?
If it were three carbons, and
you wanted it to be attacked
by a high HOMO?
STUDENT: R-Cl.
PROFESSOR: A halide would
do it, right?
The sigma* of an alkyl halide
would do that.
Now suppose you wanted it to be
the high HOMO.
Then what would you do?
Megan, you just told us about
that.
Suppose you wanted R to be a
high HOMO.
STUDENT: A metal.
PROFESSOR: You'd use a metal, an
alkyl metal.
OK.
Now, how about the electrophile
on the right?
Here's a great example of use-
the-low-LUMO-of-carbonyl.
So now what we want on the left
is the high HOMO.
We want the alkyl metal.
But we can only start from
alcohols.
In fact, we can't even start
with this, because that's a
carbon that goes into the
product.
We have to start from an
alcohol.
So how are we going to make that
from an alcohol?
How is it related to an alcohol?
We can have a H on the carbon, H
on here.
That would be an alcohol
methanol.
What kind of reagent do we need
to get from
the alcohol to this?
Is it an oxidation?
Is it a reduction?
Is it neither?
STUDENT: Oxidation.
PROFESSOR: We have to remove two
hydrogens.
It's an oxidation.
There's a problem, though.
Because the oxidizing agents
that oxidize alcohols also
react with aldehydes.
If you have any water there,
water will add, make the
aldehyde into a diol,
and then that will react.
That will get oxidized by the
reagent.
How do you avoid that?
We talked about this last time.
You don't have any water
there, right?
So we talked about that last
time.
Pyridinium chlorochromate, done
in methylene chloride
solvent, so there's no water
there, you can do that trick.
So we have the electrophile.
Now we need the nucleophile.
We need a C3 group with a metal
on it.
But we can only start with an
alcohol.
So if we had normal propyl
Grignard reagent, that would
do the trick.
Where do you get a Grignard
reagent from?
RMgBr.
What's the starting material?
So you guys need to go through
this to get a little drill
under your belts.
You get Grignard reagents from
alkyl halides.
So we could get RMgBr from
magnesium and alkyl bromide.
But where do we get the alkyl
bromide?
Night The rules of the game has
us starting with alcohol.
Yea, Amy?
STUDENT: You can start with
PBr3.
PROFESSOR: PBr3 on the alcohol.
So we got it.
OK.
So we could make that first one.
Now how about the second one?
Now we need an electrophile and
a nucleophile.
The electrophile, now on the
left, could be the
ethylmagnesium bromide, just two
carbons.
And we would make it the same
way here, starting with
ethanol instead of propanol.
So that one's OK.
Now, what will the group on the
right be?
We want to be able to attack
this carbon and end up with OH
on the adjacent carbon.
Now, you haven't done a lot of
problems like this, but you
need to think them through
and whatever textbook you're
using, you'll find
problems of this sort.
So try some of them.
But we talked about such a
reaction, which is an epoxide.
Remember?
The strained rings could be
attacked by a nucleophile to
open here to form this ring,
where you attack this carbon
and the O comes away as the
leaving group, protonated.
Now, where do we get that from?
Where does an epoxide come from?
We have to start with an
alcohol.
Any reactions that give
epoxides?
They come by adding oxygen to an
alkene.
Anybody remember the reagents
that'll add an oxygen?
STUDENT: Osmium?
PROFESSOR: What?
STUDENT: Osmium something,
tetrachloride?
PROFESSOR: Say again?
STUDENT: Osmium?
PROFESSOR: No.
The osmium petroxide takes an
alkene and puts two Os on it.
That'll put two Os.
We want to just put one O in the
middle.
And you'll kick yourself when--
oh yeah, Chris?
STUDENT: HOCl, I think you do it
with something else.
PROFESSOR: You can add Cl and OH
and then remove HCl.
That was one way of doing it.
There's another way where you do
it in one step.
STUDENT: mCPBA.
PROFESSOR: mCPBA,
meta-chloroperbenzoic acid.
Remember that cyclic butterfly
mechanism that transferred the
oxygen from the peroxy acid?
OK, so we got that.
But now we need the alkene, but
we only
have available alcohols.
But that's a trivial one.
Just dehydrate[correction:
eliminate from] an alcohol, or
dehydrate an alkyl bromide.
So you treat with strong base,
and remove HBr,
and you got the thing.
OK.
So we've got that.
We can do that one with heat and
NaOH.
Now, how about the bottom one?
That one is quite a problem.
The problem is that you could
have methyl Grignard, but what
are you going to attack?
Because if you had a
four-membered ring here with
oxygen, it wouldn't open.
It's not strained like the
three-membered ring would be.
And if you try to make the
nucleophile be on the left,
that top right carbon being an
anion, and this one being,
say, formaldehyde, then
you have the problem
that you'd get an OH here.
And that's a problem, because
you have to get rid of just
one of the two OHs.
Or you would have to have a
Grignard reagent, or something
like here, and that would react
with its own H.
Now, you could imagine
complicated schemes where you
use protecting groups, and stuff
like that.
So it's conceivable, but it's
hard work.
because this is not a
particularly good carbon to be
to be reactive.
So it's not in an activated
position.
This one was in a position where
it could have been
attached to that oxygen.
This one was in a position that
was a carbonyl.
But this one has no special
virtues that make it reactive,
so that one is the tough one to
make.
OK.
Now let's think about the second
one.
Let's try to make that bond, for
example, right?
Now we need a nucleophile and an
electrophile.
Does anybody have an idea what
the low LUMO is that could be
attacked in order to make that
red bond?
Yigit, you have an idea?
We want to make this
carbon-carbon bond, and one of
the two carbons has to be a high
HOMO, and the other an
unusually low LUMO.
And notice, incidentally, that
this one that needs to be one
of them has an oxygen next door.
STUDENT: Yeah, that's carbon
double bond with O; pi*.
PROFESSOR: Carbon double bond
with O, right?
So then what would you use on
the right?
STUDENT: You need a nucleophile,
so,
RCl.
PROFESSOR: RCl is like R plus,
right?
You want R minus.
You want a high HOMO, not the
low LUMO.
Not sigma*.
And what would you use?
STUDENT: R-Metal.
PROFESSOR: It's a metal, right.
OK.
So we need a nucleophile and an
electrophile.
We use the three carbons on the
right
as a Grignard reagent.
And now we need that aldehyde,
right?
That four-carbon aldehyde.
We can only start with three
carbon things, so we can't
oxidize one of the things they
give us,
and make that aldehyde.
How are we going to make that
four carbon aldehyde?
Any ideas?
You don't have to look far.
Linda do you have an idea?
You need four carbons that
terminate in oxygen, double
bond O. And you can only start
with three carbons.
Can you think of any way of
making four carbons when you
start with three or less?
That was the first problem,
right?
So you've already made this.
Can you think of any way of
making the aldehyde?
How do you go from the alcohol
to the aldehyde?
What do you need to do?
You need to remove two Hs.
Right?
It's an oxidation reaction.
So think only of oxidizing
agents.
Can you think of any oxidizing
agent that the changes an
alcohol to an aldehyde?
STUDENT: [very quietly]PCC.
PROFESSOR: Sebastian?
STUDENT: Br2.
PROFESSOR: Br2 can do it.
But you're going to have
problems, depending on how you
do it, of over oxidation.
The aldehydes can
go on to acids.
STUDENT: PCC.
PROFESSOR: PCC, the same one we
used on the last slide.
So you treat that one as PCC in
the
methylene chloride solvent.
You got that aldehyde.
So we've solved the second one.
PCC and methylene chloride.
Now, the next one that they
suggest you try to
make is this one.
Suppose you wanted to make that
bond.
Can you think of any way of
doing it?
Ellen?
What's going to be the
nucleophile?
STUDENT: the R-Metal.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What's the R going to be?
Is it on the right or the left,
the one we're going to--
that's going to be the R-Metal
that we're going to deal with?
Is it going to be this carbon or
this carbon?
The bottom-right or the top-left
carbon?
What's the top-left carbon going
to be in order
to make that bond?
Amy?
STUDENT: It'll be another C=O.
PROFESSOR: C=O. When we see the
O next to the
carbon, we think aldehyde.
That's going to be the LUMO that
gets attacked.
And the HOMO? Ellen?
STUDENT: The one on the right.
PROFESSOR: The one on the right
is going to be a Grignard.
But this time, instead of
n-propyl, it's isopropyl.
And this is the aldehyde we
need.
Any way of getting
that aldehyde Ellen?
STUDENT: Yeah, it's the
same one.
PROFESSOR: It's the same one
above.
So we got that one.
OK.
Now how about this one?
Any ideas for that?
So let's make that bond.
So what gets attacked
on the left?
Amy you want to help us again?
STUDENT: Well, it would
be...isn't it the to...
or the second one?
PROFESSOR: How many carbons on
the left?
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
We can only start with three
carbon alcohols.
STUDENT: Could you make the
second product and then there's
some kind of shift?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
But the second product has the
seven with an
alcohol in the middle.
So what do you do?
You need a ketone in the middle.
You've made the alcohol.
You need the ketone.
So you have to oxidize it.
So you could use the same
reagent again, but you don't
need to worry, because it's a
ketone this time, so you're
not so worried about
overoxidation, so you could
use one of those chromate things
that we talked about,
or bromine, or anything.
And on the right, it's just the
n-propyl again.
We've already made that.
OK.
So we got that one made.
What if we wanted to make the
next bond, the
vertical bond, instead?
Oh.
I didn't show it here.
Well, what if we needed to make
the vertical bond?
It's the same thing.
Right?
The thing is symmetrical.
It has three propyl groups on
there.
OK.
So here's another one.
How are we going to make this
one?
Well, we could make that bond.
Anybody see how to do that?
Mary? What are we going to use
on the right?
STUDENT: We're going to use the
same reagents.
PROFESSOR: The same one as here,
isopropyl.
OK.
And what's on the left?
STUDENT: We're going to oxidize
the oxygen...
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's going to be the
same one as above...
STUDENT: Yeah, and then we're
going to add isopropyl.
PROFESSOR: that seven-carbon.
So we've got that one.
And now finally, how about if we
wanted to
make that one instead?
Then what would the Grignard
reagent be?
It would be n-propyl instead of
isopropyl.
And what would the ketone be?
It would be this.
And where would we get that?
By oxidizing this one.
And finally this one.
Now, we could imagine making
this bond, or making this
bond, or making this bond.
And we have the means to do all
these things now.
But one wonders, is there a
preferred order?
Is one way of doing this better
than the others?
And in this case, I suspect that
they're
all about the same.
It might come down to what's
cheap and available and so on,
which alcohols are cheaper.
And in fact, of course, you
would never do this, because
simple things like this, you
wouldn't start from the
alcohol, you'd buy the bromide
or something like that.
But when you talk about
versatility of Grignard
reagents, there are other things
they can do, too.
For example, if you try to make
the diisopropyl methyl
version of the carbinol here to
make this one, you find
that you can first make the
salt, then treat it with acid,
you get that alcohol, and it's
95% yield.
Great.
Now, suppose you want to use
t-butyl instead of methyl.
Right?
So you want to get that one.
So you try that reaction, and
you get 0% yield of that.
The product is this.
So what was it that added to the
carbonyl?
It wasn't the t-butyl anion.
What anion was it?
What did the addition?
It was hydride.
But where did the hydride come
from?
So it was a reduction by H
minus, or the
equivalent of H minus.
What you had was the t-butyl
Grignard.
Now, what problem did t-butyl
Grignard have in trying to
form this alcohol? Yeah Cassie?
STUDENT: It's sterically
hindered.
PROFESSOR: It's sterically
The carbon can't get close to
the carbon.
But a hydrogen can get close to
That beta hydrogen can get close
to the carbon.
So now we can do this.
And you see that the carbon part
that was t-butyl loses
magnesium and loses H to become
the alkene, and the
other product, then, is that 65%
yield alcohol.
And this reminds you, this
hydrogen transfer from
t-butyl, although it's happening
here in the context
of an anion, it reminds you of
two t-butyl radicals having
trouble forming a carbon-carbon
bond and
transferring a hydrogen atom
instead for the same reason,
to avoid steric hindrance.
OK.
Now, if you use t-butyl CH2
magnesium bromide, then you
don't have to worry about this
hydride transfer.
Because it has CH2 in this
position, and three methyls
attached to that carbon.
There is no hydrogen in the beta
position, so it looks
like we're home free, here.
But you only get a 4% yield of
the Grignard, right?
Because it's still sterically
hindered.
What you get instead is
protonation of
the neopentyl group.
So remember that the ketone
itself has alpha hydrogens.
So you can form enolates, you
can give up
a proton from those.
So this thing which is a
nuclophile is also a strong
base, and can take that off, and
you get that one plus the
enolate, which lost the proton.
But then when you work it up
with acid, you protonate it
again, so the ketone gets
recovered, 90% of it, and your
carefully made Grignard reagent
just becomes the
hydrocarbon.
No use there.
OK.
So those are other things that
can happen
with Grignard reagents.
And that same thing,
incidentally, can happen here,
because the alpha hydrogen was
present here, and this one was
a strong base, and in fact 35%
of that one was that plus the
starting ketone after you put
the proton back on.
Now, if you try to make this
bond, you could make it with--
notice the difference this time
is that it's isopropyl
instead of t-butyl group here.
So you could try doing this.
So that has an H beta and steric
hindrance, so there's
the risk that it would give
reduction.
But if you started with that
ketone and added methyl
Grignard, then the methyl
doesn't have any hydrogen beta
that it could give in reduction,
so now you get a
good yield of the product that
you wanted.
So sometimes it's helpful to
choose one of
the bonds to make.
So in trying to make this
alcohol, the thing you get
when you protonate here, you
could make this bond or this
bond or this bond.
But the bonds to methyl are much
more practical to make
than the bond to the CH2 because
of the risk of reduction.
OK.
Now, the Wittig reaction we can
zoom through, because you
all know that from lab.
I don't remember what base you
used to
make the Wittig reagent.
Do you remember?
STUDENT: Sodium hydroxide.
PROFESSOR: Sodium what?
STUDENT: Hydroxide.
PROFESSOR: Hydroxide.
So you didn't have such a simple
Wittig
reagent as this one.
Notice that here you make the
reagent by reacting with
bromide, just like nitrogen
would do-- an SN2 reaction.
Now you have that cation, and
you treat it, in this case,
with a very strong base.
Butyl lithium.
So a carbon anion.
What's the pH[correction: pK3]
of a
carbon-hydrogen bond, typically?
Just like butane losing a
proton?
STUDENT: 50.
PROFESSOR: Order of 50, right?
Very weak acid.
So the butyl lithium is a very
strong base, and pulls that
proton off the CH2.
Now in this case, the pKa is
about 30 of the CH3 group to
lose a proton.
You're never going to get that
off with hydroxide.
But you can do it in this case
with a stronger base.
But what is it that...you
couldn't do this if, instead
of phosphorus, you had nitrogen.
Now, what's good about forming
this anion?
Why is that anion a reasonable
one to try to make, where you
don't pull hydrogens off carbons
willy-nilly, not off
normal hydrocarbons?
What does the neighboring
phosphorus have to do with it?
How does it make it easy to form
the anion?
Well, the phosphorus is a
cation.
It's easy to form an anion near
the cation.
You could do that with nitrogen,
"It could have been
N plus, the next
neighbor up in the periodic
table, right?
But phosphorus is even better.
Because when you get that anion
to be stabilized,
phosophorus, down in the next
row of the periodic table, has
vacant d-orbitals that are able
to
stabilize that electron.
So it's especially acidic, but
not so acidit that you're
going to pull it off with OH
minus.
So you could draw a resonance
structure where you have a
double bond, where not only the
phosphorus has given
electrons to the carbon in
making the bond, but the
carbon has given electrons back
to the phosphorus
through this d-orbital or
interaction.
Anyhow, you have this the
so-called ylide, and then it
can act as a nucleophile with a
carbonyl, and now the
oxygen can add to the
phosphorus, which can form
five bonds, because it has extra
valence orbitals, these
d-orbitals.
So you get the four-membered
ring.
But that very easily unzips
because the PO double bond is
unusually stable.
The NO bond of a trivalent
nitrogen that then adds
oxygen, is only seventy
kilocalories per mole, but the
phosphorus version is 100
kilocalories per mole, because
of those d-orbitals making it
especially stable.
OK.
So you can get that
triphenylphosphene oxide and
the alkene, and as you know,
what the Wittig reaction
results in is replacing double
bond O by double bond CH2, or
in other cases, double bond C
something else, depending on
what you started with up here.
And I say directly--
because there are other ways of
going roundabout to do
this, rather than to do it
directly.
For example, you could add a
methyl Grignard to this ketone
to make the alcohol.
Treat that with acid, lose the
water to make the primary
cation, and it could then lose a
proton.
And that would replace--
here's what our CH2 is coming
from, right?
And then we lose the H from the
CH3 to get that.
So that replaces the double bond
O with double bond CH2.
The same thing the Wittig
reaction would do, except
that's not the major product.
It's a minor product.
What's the other product?
The other product is losing a
different alpha hydrogen.
One of those.
That's the major product.
Why?
It's a more stable alkene, more
highly substituted.
So you can see the advantage of
the Wittig reaction, which
directly gives the replacement
of double bond O by double
bond CH2, in this case, or
double bond CHR,
or double bond CR2.
Now, I was going to say a little
bit about green
chemistry in connection with
some of these reactions we're
talking about.
So pharmaceuticals are a big
chemical industry nowadays.
A hundred years ago, it would
still have been dye industry.
And then petroleum,
pharmaceuticals, plastics.
But now, pharmaceuticals
generate only 0.2% of the
chemical industry's product,
measured by mass, but 25% of
its value in money.
Which means that it's worth
doing a lot of work on those
to do a lot of reactions in
order to get these
pharmaceuticals.
There's a lot of value added.
But in the process of doing all
these manipulations, the
pharmaceutical industry
generates more than 50% of the
chemical waste.
So the idea of green chemistry
is to find new ways of doing
things that won't generate so
much waste, or will be safer,
for example.
So there's a journal called
Green Chemistry, and in 2000,
they published a paper called
"Key Green Chemistry Research
Areas: A Perspective from
Pharmaceutical Manufacturers."
So representatives of the
biggest pharmaceutical
companies, AstraZeneca,
GlaxoSmithKline, Lilly,
Pfizer, Merck, Schering-Plough,
which is now
part of Merck, got together to
talk about what they saw as
the places where you could make
advances to make
chemistry more friendly to the
environment and to the people
practicing it.
And obviously from the
perspective of the
pharmaceutical industry.
So this is gazing in a crystal
ball, and there's nothing as
hard to predict as the future.
But at least these are their
ideas, and they're people that
have a great practical interest
in it, not only in
the sense of there are things
they want to happen, but they're
willing to give money to people
to try to
help make it happen,
to do research projects, to try
to develop new
ways of doing it.
So they were trying to decide
what they would most like to
have. So it involves frequency
of use.
If there's a reaction you hardly
ever use, you don't
want to spend a lot of trouble
on that one.
But if there's something that
you use all the time that you
could make better, then that's
important.
So frequency of use.
How much volume is involved of
the stuff.
If it's only a milligram, who
cares?
But if it's tons, that's a big
deal.
And of course, safety is another
one.
So one of the top priorities is
solvents, because that's
what they use the most of.
And something that wouldn't
occur to the outsider,
probably, is a very important
thing is to clean the-- they
have these big reaction vessels
and they have to clean
them so that stuff that's left
over from the previous
reaction doesn't get into some
other drug.
So they have to be scrupulously
cleaned.
And two thirds of the solvent
they use is used in cleaning
the reactors to make sure that
they're clean.
But there might be other ways of
doing it.
For example, use water and an
oxidizing agent like hydrogen
peroxide maybe to do it.
So anyhow, they're interested in
that as one of the big
steps they could take.
Or replacements for what are
called aprotic solvents.
So these are organic solvents.
They'll dissolve organic
compounds.
But they also typically dissolve
salt.
So you can have salts react with
organic compounds in
these solvents.
So ones like NMP there on the
left, N-Methylpyrrolidone or
dimethylacetamide, or
dimethylformamide are very
heavily used solvents, because
you can mix organic and salt
reagents in them.
But the problem is that they're
very difficult--
because they're
miscible with water,
they're very hard to get out of
the water at
the end of the day.
They're worried about polluting
water streams. So
they would like to get
replacements for that.
Now, you could wish for
anything.
You could wish for $2 billion.
I'd like to have $2 billion now;
I'm willing to split it with all
of you guys.
That doesn't mean it's going to
happen.
And so you can see a real
problem with this.
The reason these solvents are
good is because they're
organic and they're miscible
with water.
But the misciblity with water is
what makes them bad,
because it's hard to get out of
the water again.
So I don't know what progress
has been made on this.
But anyhow, it's something that
they would really like.
But then they thought of
thirteen processes, that is,
not just solvents but actual
reactions that need improving.
And the ones that they already
use heavily.
And fourteen, they suggested new
processes that there isn't
a good way to do now, but would
really be handy if you
could do them.
And then they voted.
So there were six companies
represented doing the voting,
and each of them could cast five
votes to choose among the
thirteen processes that need
improving, and another five
votes among the fourteen
processes that they would like
to have available.
So this is the perspective from
the people who really do
it about what would be useful to
do.
So current processes that need
reviewing.
All six of them voted that a way
of forming amides,
avoiding poor atom economy
reagents.
Now, what that means is you're
just trying to put this
nitrogen onto a carboxylic acid
to make an amide.
But if you use other reagents
that have an enormous number
of atoms in it, then
necessarily, you're going to
have an enormous amount of waste
generated.
But if you could do it with
atom-economy, so you have a
minimum number of atoms going
in, in order to--
ideally would be just the
element you want to have added
to the molecule, right?
For example, a catalyst might
allow you to do that, where a
stoichiometric reagent, where
you have to add a whole mole
of it, wouldn't do it.
So then OH activation for
nucleophilic substitution.
This is something we've talked
about a lot.
You make the OH, you protonate
it, you make it into an acid
chloride, you make it into a
tosylate
with the leaving group.
But this is something that five
of these industries still
say is one of the most important
things to develop.
A better way of
activating OH for
nucleus[correction:
nucleophilic] substitution.
Reduction of amides, the
carbonyl group in amides,
without using hydrides.
So they say, lithium aluminum
hydride, having a molecular
weight of 38 and four hydrides
per molecule, has the highest
hydride density.
So from the terms of
atom-economy, it's very good.
But it co-generates an inorganic
byproduct which is
difficult to separate from the
product, and that makes the
filtration slow, you lose
product when you're trying to
filter it, get absorbed in this
extra junk
that's being made.
So they need something better
than the
available hydride reagents.
Or to be able to do oxidation or
epoxidation without using a
chlorinated solvent.
Four of them said that was a top
priority.
And they noticed, in connection
with the oxidation,
that using the kinds of metals,
like chromium or
osmium, that we've talked about,
or manganese, these
have virtually been eliminated
from pharmaceutical processes,
because small amounts of these
metals could be injurious to
the health.
So the FDA requires that there
be none in there.
So better is to use oxidizing
agents that don't involve such
metals when you're making
pharmaceuticals.
OK.
Then safer and more
environmentally friendly
Mitsunobu reactions.
Now, we're going to talk about
the Mitsunobu reaction next.
But three said that was
important, so it's
worth knowing what the
Mitsunobu reaction is, if they
think it's so important.
Friedel-Crafts reactions on
unactivated systems. We talked
about substituents that were
activating or deactivating.
But there are not good ways,
they say, of doing their
Friedel-Crafts reactions on
unactivated systems. At least
two of them said that.
And two of them said nitrations
was a problem,
not because the reaction's hard
to do,
but because of the danger of
explosion with nitric acid.